[Applause]
welcome to eat you live if you couldn't
already tell we are live right now with
the caster's super girls this is a tease
very last interview from comic-con this
is super girls very last interview at
comic-con we're gonna call this insane a
little weird
sorry not sorry I had the pleasure of
moderating your comic-con panel earlier
today so fans who are watching right now
probably worked in the audience so we're
gonna kind of have a mini summarization
of all the amazing points that you guys
talked about on the panel today for the
fans who are at home you can watch the
season 3 sizzle reel because in it
you're going to see very hot but in it
you will see a surprisingly I don't want
to say dark super girl also member
summers ladybird Finney that's a smile
from what she's she weren't too happy
people I think it's because she shot her
boyfriend off into space yeah but in the
trailer you say car Danvers was a
mistake what do you think she means by
that uh those are pretty heavy words
[Music]
the parents did the first year was
really about embracing her Supergirl
sides yes season 2 was about finding
that balance season 3 it was just super
girl full force yes she's got these
scales going all the time trying to
balance everything as a woman that's a
superhero and love and pot stickers rear
pot stickers and pizza and ice cream oh
boy now it's all the rocks of the scale
or on Supergirl
all the Dwayne Johnson's that she is
most distraught because you know there's
a high amount of lead in the air and
earth right now she had to send ma Nell
yeah away for his safety right but yeah
I mean someone who's lost their entire
world and almost her entire family
knowing sanctimony she lost her entire
world and she probably has some
abandonment issues make so and she's
dealing with that yeah well Chris you
actually I got Roberto to say on the
panel today that Montel will return yeah
so that's exciting for the fans out
there and also you're sitting here right
now I'm sitting here as surely as air is
briefing in my mouth you guys okay he's
a hologram though oh my god my hand go
through what what can you tell us about
what Manos let me write down nada mucho
okay work with me he okay there there
was a pod yes in this spatial ness went
through a wormhole her pod got knocked
off-course
intrusive or old-fashioned his pod got
knocked off-course every pod is knocked
off course except Paulo
why do we trust it's physically the same
Katie with the Epiphany right now Tony
empandas on earth I know I'm coming in
as our new villain rain yes your pod
made it they were just fine
I should are we are we gonna regret
there her pod got there safe absolutely
I'm coming into trouble I'm the greatest
villain in this way and not like I've
said that before
what up world killer yeah bioengineer
you K but I not going to because I think
she's gonna be what you have lasted lady
oh really yeah engineer barrel killer
does a really nice work with the SPCA
yeah how long how long is the bomb
my mommy's departed in in space space
yeah and it's in its work okay bring it
back to the process of my power
how long is your pocket we knocked off
course we don't know I mean what is mine
well I can say no the show takes place
Jerry's trying to tell us something
first episode takes place six months
after the what would you two like to see
from Cara and Mon L when this eventual
reunion happens yeah the first first
step is no coming dream with me yes yes
dream what would you like to see from
the two of them in season two earth
three I don't know if we can answer that
without knowing what yeah we're kind of
in the dark yeah we are a bit I would
like to see them get back together be
happy I'm happy
I would like to watch well continue
kickin ass you are you are first of all
you and I are talking about this not on
the panel when we were walking from the
green room to the panel then you always
have the most uncomfortable outfits on
the show when are we gonna get to see
Lena just kick back in some like tennis
shoes but this is what I think if you
were a billionaire wouldn't you just go
to work in your pajamas yes like your
company I would work I just know
into marriage ceremony with you know
let's talk a little bit about past
relationships
he went from Lucy Lane Lucy first of all
wait John can you let her out no but
she's teaching my where should not be
concerned about as a missing person we
don't use a lot of season one characters
are just I mean
really easy thing to do deposits what's
you're looking for in season three and
eleven turists what am I looking for in
season three for a love interest for
James what am I looking for
season three in a V yeah what she
looking for at this point you want to
try and give me a simple answer from a
simple man I don't have an answer for
you I mean like it's it's they're gonna
hire somebody who's fantastic or maybe
they already have hearts and minds
fantastic
maybe it's someone in this room who's
I'm looking for saying yeah yeah I don't
know now we're just gonna end it right
on Jeremy just say whatever you want
yeah winds gonna be a lot of fun as
always it's gonna crack some jokes you
gonna be you know the little kind of
who's gonna take things down you know
hopefully get everybody from being so
dark and deep and pull them into you
know some fun times and at the same time
I think we're gonna probably delve into
a little bit of his past as well which
may be less fun times but you know yeah
I'm excited to see where Windows is here
but you know he's always a lot of fun
I'm pretty sure this has been a No
not Holly's gonna be upset pelvis so
we're getting a four part crossover this
fall and it's gonna be a true four part
oh yeah where's Supergirl is actually
involved this year yeah who you'd like
to see your characters interact with my
personal pictures I really like to be
win Felicity and Cisco all that drink
together and commiserate over the fact
that they're always just like and then I
had to create this for this scenario
that's true yeah and then my now kills
the Green Arrow it's a big cross the new
girl right you're starting you guys this
has been delightfully weird I like it
you're welcome I like you guys I like
Supergirl season three you guys tune in
thank you so much for stopping